مقتل ضابط شرطه كبير اثناء التعامل مع
اعمال شغب في معان جنوبي الاردن وتعزيزات
امنيات تتوجه للمنطقه
انقاذ القانون في اوروبا تبحث مكافحه
الانشطه الارهابيه وغير المشروع لحزب الله
في افريقيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
اعلنت مديريه الامن العام الاردنيه مقتل
العقيد عبد الرزاق عبد الحافظ الدلابيح
نائب مدير شرطه محافظه
الحسينيه في محافظه معان واكدت مديريه
الامن العام انها مستمره في عملها لحفظ
الامن الوطني
اخر افاده الامن العام الاردني باصابه
ضابط
صف بعيارات الناريه في منطقه الحسينيه
بمعان جنوب الاردن
هذا واقد انتشرت قوه وتعزيزات امنيه في
مدينتي الكرك والبتراء جنوب الاردن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
محمد
كما صدر بيان عن وجهاء محافظه معان عقب
مقتل نائب مدير شرطه المحافظه واصابه
عنصرين اخرين اعلنوا فيه التبرؤ من اي شخص
يرفع سراحه في وجه اي عسكريا او مدني
لمعرفه المزيد مشاهدينا من التفاصيل عن
الوضع في الاردن معنى الان من عمان مراسل
العربيه عماد العضلات اهلا بك يا عماد ما
هي الاوضاع في جنوب الاردن الان في منطقه
معان هل انتهت هذه الاشتباكات وساده
الهدوء امانه
نعم انا الان يعني متواجد في محافظه الكرك
جنوبا وهي ايضا من المحافظات التي شهدت
ااا احتجاجات يوم امس وصباح اليوم يعني
الحوت الهدوء عاد الى المنطقه بشكل كامل
وبشكل يعني شامل في كافه المحافظات
محافظات الجنوب وحتى المحافظات بعض
المحافظات المحافظات الشمال التي شهدت
ايضا بعض الاحتجاجات التي سيطر عليها
الامن العام يوم امس بعد مقتل همم الضابط
الدلابيح همم كانت توجهت هناك قوه امنيه
همم مكثفه وساده في المنطقه في منطقه
الحسينيه وهي منطقه تقع على همم الطريق
الصحراوي الممتاز من الذي يربط ما بين
عمان وما بين ايضا محافظ
عماد لماذا اندلعت يعني لمن لم همم لا
يعرف تفاصيل ما جرى
الحكومه الاردنيه ترسل الموازنه العامه
لمجلس النواب هذه الموازنه بالعاده تتضمن
همم لدعم من قبل الحكومه للمحروقات بقيمه
تصل الى نصف همم نصف مليار
دينار سنويا لتثبيته عن هذا الدعم لتثبيت
همم المحروقات على المواطنين وعدم فرض
ضريبهم هذه السنه وقبل حتى 10 ايام تقريبا
همم الحكومه ارسلت هذه الموازنه العامه
ولم تتضمن دعم المحروقات وهذا يعني ان
سعرها سعر المحروقات
وعندما ارتفعت يعني اسعار خاصه ماده
الديزل وماده همم الكاز
قام
سائقي الشاحنات
بالاضراب عن العمل وامتدت هذه الاضرابات
امتدت الى يعني الشحنات التي تنقل البضائع
طبعا
وامتدت هذه الاضرابات لتصل الى وسائل
النقل العام بالاضافه الى التكاسي والى
ايضا
بعض
المركبات التي تعمل على تطبيقات الذكيه
همم من هنا بدات يعني اعتصامات سلميه
واضراب عن العمل بعدها او قبل ثلاثه ايام
بدات احتجاجات احتجاجات همم يعني محدوده
واعمال شغب محدوده ادت الى اغلاق بعض
الطرق الفرعيه في محافظات الجنوب من هذه
الاحتجاجات همم يعني احدى هذه الاحتجاجات
كانت التي تم استغلالها من قبل همم يعني
اشخاص وتم اطلاق النار على همم القوه
الامنيه واطلاق النار على الضابط ما ادى
الى مقتل
الضابط الدلابيق واصابه اثنين اخرين هل هي
الاعمال يعني عندما بدات كان الامن العام
يتعامل معها فقط لتهدئه الوضع وتهدئه يعني
اعاده المشهد الى ما كان عليه سابقا اليوم
بعد مقتل الضابط هناك بالتاكيد الامن
العام وكما جاء في بيان الامن العام انها
ستعامل
بكل همم يعني همم تتعامل بكل قوه وبكل حزم
همم لكل يعني كل همم تسوي نفسه نفسه
واطلاق النار
يعني زياده اعمال تصل الى اطلاق النار على
همم
الشرطه كما راينا ف- طيب سنكون معك كل هذه
التفاصيل الحاله ورودها شكرا جزيلا لكم
مراسل العربيه كان معنا من الكرك جنوب
الاردن
اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي مانو المكان
اعلن رئيس روسي بلاديمير او عفوا الرئيس
الروسي الاوكراني
القوات الروسيه استضافت خيرسون يوم امس
باكثر من سته او سته عشره غراء ما اسفر عن
سقوطي قتيلين وادى الانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن المدينه
وحشيه على احد وصفه
الرئيس الاوكرانيين في الغد ميرسي توجه
بشكري ايضا لسحماء الاتحاد الاوروبي على
العقوبات التي تم فرضها على روسيا وعلى
حزمه المساعده الماليه لاوكرانيا والتي
تقدر بثمانيه عشر مليار يورو
اود ان اشكركم على خطوات العقوبات التي
اتخذتموها خلال الاشهر السته الماضيه وعلى
حزمه الدعم المالي لبلدنا العام المقبل
بمبلغ 18 مليار يورو والتي يمكن الموافقه
عليها اخيرا على مستوى القياده هذا امر
مهم للغايه
ايضا في الشق الاقتصادي للحرب في اوكرانيا
قالت الوكاله الدوليه لضمان الاستثمار وهي
ذراع مجموعه البنك الدولي قالت انها اطلقت
حزمه دعم بقيمتي مليارات دولار لاوكرانيا
وذلك للمساعده في بناء مرونه القطاع الخاص
الاوكراني الذي دمرته الحرب الروسيه ومن
اجل الاستعداد لاعاده الاعمار
[موسيقى]
وكان رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
ان المجلس الاوروبي سيمنح اوكرانيا
مساعدات بقيمه ثمانيه عشر مليار
يوروبي
من ناحيه سنقدم مبلغ 18 مليار يورو على
شكل مساعده ماليه لاوكرانيا وهذا امر
ملموس ويظهر ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يحافظ
على التزاماته وعلى كلمته انها فرصه
مناسبه لاطلعكم باننا اتخذنا قرارات تهدف
الى دعم السلام الاوروبي ومن الواضح ان
هذا مهم جدا لاوكرانيا وربما لمناطق اخرى
عمل مستشار الالمانيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي الثابت في الدفاع عن
سيادتها وسلامه اراضيها
منذ البدايه الرئيس الاوكراني كان معنا
مره اخرى اليوم رسالتنا اليهم تظل كما هي
اوكرانيا
قلل متحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
باتريك رايدر ان الجيش الامريكي سيوسع
تدريبه لافراد الجيش الاوكراني في المانيا
مما في ذلك التدريب على اسلحه المشتركه
واضاف الرايدر ان تدريبات الجديده ستشمل
حوالي 500 او 500 اوكراني بالفعل شهريا
ولن تتطلب زياده في نشر القوات الامريكيه
في اوروبا
اهالي مدينه ابدنان الايرانيه يحتفلون
بعوده الشابه سونيا شريف بعد اطلاق سراحها
من المعتقل
اهلا بكم من جديد استقبل اهالي مدينه
ابدنان الكردي بمحافظه علام غربي ايران
استقبلوا سونيا شريف بترحيب والاهازيج عقب
خروجها من معتقل مركز اعلام الاصلاحي
بكفاله بعد قرابه شهر من اعتقالها
[موسيقى]
عروض
ايوه
على وزير الداخليه الايرانيه احمد وحيدي
العمل على حزب العالم الافتراضي في ايران
بشكل كامل لمواجهه من وصفهم بالاعداء
الذين يعملون على صنع برامج لرفع الحجم
بالاضافه الى تشكيل لجنه لتحقيق في
الاضطرابات الاخيره في البلاد وتقديم
المتهمين للقضاء وكان نظام الايراني قد
نفى اجراءات سابقا في حجم تلغرام ومواقع
التواصل بعد اندلاع التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه
ضد غلاء المعيشه وتدني الاجور
تداول ان ننشيطون على تويتر مقطع فيديو
يظهروا فيه المتظاهرين الايراني مجيد رضا
رهن ورد قبل ان يقوم النظام الايراني
باعدامه شنقا وهو يوجه رساله الى شباب
الايراني قائلا لا تبكي كن سعيدا واستمع
الى الموسيقى لتكون سعيده اكثر
القانون في اوروبا يوم الاربعاء والخميس
ركز على مكافحه الانشطه الارهابيه وغير
المشروع لحزب الله في افريقيا
الحكومات والمنظمات من جميع انحاء افريقيا
الى جانب الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
وليفربول
كيف يواصلوا حزب الله جمع الاموال في
القاره السمراء باستخدام كل من الوسائل
المشروعه وغير المشروعه
من تطبيق القانون والجهود التنظيميه
الملكيه
في واقعه اطلاق النار على قافله اليونيفيل
في لبنان والتي اسفرت عن مقتل جنديا
ايرلندي دانت سفاره الامريكيه في لبنان
باشد العبارات الهجوم على قوات حفظ السلام
التابعه للامثال وقالت سفاره الامريكيه في
بيان ان العنف ضد قوات حفظ السلام هو تصرف
غير مسؤول ويعرض المدنيين اللبنانيين
والاستقرار في جنوب لبنان
سفاره الامريكيه الحكومه اللبنانيه لتحقيق
عاجل في الهجوم ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنه
ومنع تكرار ذلك مستقبلا
تحول تجمع الذي يدعى اكرم امام اوغلو رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول الذي دعا انصاره اليه بعد
يومين من صدور حكم من ادانته في قضيته
لمده عامين وسبعه اشهر ونصف تحول الى ما
يشبه احتجاجات غاضبا انضم اليها الالاف
بينهم زعماء احزاب معارضين
لم تمنع الاجواء البارده الاف المناصرين
لرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم من التظاهر دعما
له ضد قرار محكمه تركيا قضاء سجنه لمده
عامين وسبعه اشهر وحضره من العمل السياسي
احزاب المعارضه تضامن مع امام بلو
والله
يا باشا
رئيس البلديه الذي صوت الناس له وارادوا
سجني بالاضافه الى ذلك ادركوا ان القاضي
المحكمه لن يحكم كما يشاؤون لذا
استبعدوه وجلبوا قاضيا اخر واتخذوا قرارهم
تجمع حضره قاده احزاب الطاوله السداسيه
وجميعهم يمثلون غالبيه المعارضه التركيه
اراد منظمه استعراض القوه في حشد الشارع
وفق ما يراه مراقبون وسط اجواء من
الحاضرين رافضه قرار المحكمه
لا يخصوا اكرم امام اوغلو لوحده بل يخص
الاراده الشعبيه ونحن لا نرضى بهذا القرار
لانهم لم يقبلوا باراده الناخبين قررت
السلطه اتخاذ هذا القرار السياسي
قرار ادانه رئيس بلديه اسطنبول لا قصته
جانا ورفضا من معظم القوى السياسيه
والنقابات والتجمعات المهنيه فضلا عن
حملات تضامن اجتاحت وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
الاول الحشد الشارع ضد قرار المحكمه
الصادر بحق رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام
اوغلو والثاني المضيفه اجراءات قانونيه
للطعن بهذا القرار زيدان زينجو العربيه
اسطنبول
انطلقت عمليات والاقتراع خرج تونس والتي
يستمر التصويت فيها لمده ثلاثه ايام معينه
بدء الانتخابات التشريعيه
في سبع دوائر انتخابيه من بين 10 فيما
تقدم مرشح وحيد بثلاث دوائر المتبقيه ما
يعني فوزه بمقاد في البرلمان المرتقب بحسب
القانون الانتخابي اما داخل البلاد
فيختتموا اليوم المترشحون للاستحقاق
البرلماني في 151 دائره دعايتهم
الانتخابيه ليكون اليوم هو يوم الصمت
الانتخابي قبل الذهاب الى صناديق الاقتراع
السبت
اكد رئيس تونسي قيس سعيدنا بلاده ترفض
لاحياز لتحالف ضد اخر وتناى بنفسها عن
سياسه المحاور وسائل الاعلام تونسيه نقلت
عن سعيد قوله ان او على هامشي مشاركته في
القمه الافريقيه الامريكيه بمواشنطن ان
العولمه تدمر نفسها بنفسها ونحن لا نريد
ان نكون من ضحاياها وقالت رئاسه التونسيه
سعيد شدد في لقاء مع رئيس لجنه العلاقه
الخارجيه بمجد مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
ونائبه على ان تونس متماسكه بسيادتها
واستقلاليه قرارها الوطني ونهم فتح على
الحوار وتشاور مع الشركاء والاصدقاء
اعترف رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في ليبيا
عبد الحميد بيبه بشكل غير مباشر بان حكومه
مشاركه في نقل مشتبه به في تفجير العقربيه
ابو عجيله محمد مسعود خير المريميه الى
الولايات المتحده الاسبوع الماضي قالت
وقالت بيبه في كلمه تلفزيونيه ان
الانتربول الدولي اصدر بحق مسعود مذكره
قبل صار بموجبها لي زمان على حكومه
التعاون من اجل مصلحه ليبيا واستقرارها
يذكر انه ليس ليبيا معاهده لتسليم مجرمين
مع الولايات المتحده
نفذ او في المملكه المتحده نافذه عشرات
والالاف من الممرضين اول الممرضات في
انجلترابا امس للمطالبه بزياده الاجور في
ظل ازمه غلاء المعيشه غير المسبوقه على ان
يتبعها اخر ايضا الاسبوع المقبل
في بريطانيا
لقلق المرضى وعائلاتهم يضربوا عشرات
الالاف من الممرضين في انجلترا
في احتجاجا هو الاكبر في تاريخ قطاع الصحه
البريطاني بعد رفض الحكومه مطالب الممرضين
بزياده رواتبهم بنسبه 19% وهي نسبه
تعتبرها الحكومه اعلى من قدره تحملها
خلال الرائحه كورونا فيما توعد رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني
قوانين جديده للحد من الاضطرابات وضمان
الحد الادنى من مستويات الخدمه
يوم ما اسوي هكذا وصف العديد الحاله التي
وصلت اليها بريطانيا التي تعاني من اوضاع
المعيشيه سيئه يشعر بها العديد من
المقيمين والعاملينا هنا
الاضراب باستخفاف ولاسيما الممرضين
الممرضين على الخط الامامي طوال الوقت
ليس كافيا وانهم بحاجه الى القيام بشيء
اكثر جوهريا
نحن مرهقون للغايه ونعاني من نقص في عدد
الموظفين منذ سنوات عديده وبشكل عام منذ
كبد
فنحو 50,000 وظيفه شاغره يعاني من نقصها
قطاع التمريض ما يعني تكدس اعداد المرضى
على لوائح الانتظار الذين وصلت اعدادهم
الى سبعه ملايين ومن المتوقع ان تطول
اللائحه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
اختتمت مساء امس وختوتمه القمه الامريكيه
الافريقيه التي استضافتها واشنطن على مدار
3 ايام بمشاركه 49 زعيما افريقيا وقد
التقطت القاده المشاركون صوره جماعيه
بحضور الرئيس الامريكي جو بعيدا الذي اكد
ان بلاده تتطلع الى زياده التعاون مع
القاره السمراء في جميع المجالات مع تركيز
على تغير المناخ والامن الغذائي وشركات
تجاريه وقضايا اخرى
علاقات تويتر حسابات اكثر من 6 صحفيين
بارزين في كبرى الصحف الامريكيه من دون
ذكر الاسباب ولكن بعض التقارير اشارتي لان
الحضره متعلق بحضر الحساب الذي كان ينشر
معلومات عن وقت عن وقت ومكان اقلاعي هبوط
طائره الخاصه بايلون ماسك
الى العناوين
مقتل ضابط شرطه كبيره اثناء التعامل مع
اعمال شغب في معان في الاردن وتعزيزتهم
امنيه تتوجه
تكنيك
مجموعه تنسيق انفاذ القانون في اوروبا
تبحث مكافحه الانشطه الارهابيه وغير
المشروع لحزب الله في افريقيا
[موسيقى]